A peasant heel in hand knitting refers
to a sock heel that is
shaped with decreases.
Instead of short rows. It is knit
in the round. For machine knitters,
shaping on the ribber is do-able
but tedious,
and here's a single bed faux peasant heel
that's a combination
of decreases and sew-as-you-go.
For this sample, I used a cast
on rag and a row of ravel cord.
Casting on the number of heel stitches
in my pattern, I knit one row
before knitting back,
I hung a bobby pin over the working yarn.
Then, working my decreases on both sides,
I used a two-step decrease
three stitches from the edge.
After the decreases are done,
I held the pin so the yarn stays tight,
and the pin isn't picked up by the
knitting carriage and knit to the right.
Before knitting back, I hung another
bobby pin on the working yarn.
Holding the pin to keep the thread tight
and the pin away from the carriage,
I knit back.
This sequence is repeated,
decreasing every other row for the number
of decreases indicated in the pattern.
On the carriage side, hang a pin,
work the decreases, knit across,
hang a pin and knit back.
When the decreases are complete,
I'll start the sew-as-you-go to form
the heel and toe pocket.
Opposite the carriage,
hang the loop being held by the pin
on an empty needle, knit across.
Opposite the carriage, hang the loop
on the next empty needle and knit across.
Keep repeating this until the original
number of needles are back in work.
The decreased side looks like the hand knit
version, and the sew-as-you-go technique
makes the shaping go fast
with no Kitchener stitch.